when John ripasso otoño was a child he
learned the centuries-old sounds of his
ancestors while listening to his
grandmother sing and watching her
traditional dances he decided to follow
in her footsteps he taught himself how
to build and master more than 10
traditional instruments like this nia TT
his need for the young ones too to get
to know the instruments get the note to
know of the land the people they are
music the environment and that's why we
decided to at least share with them the
knowledge that we have of the
instruments the word nia TT means box
the instrument is a sound box that's
tapped by the player who often taps
metal rings at the same time ripasso
holds workshops to inspire more
youngsters to play the traditional
instrument from the luo ethnic group in
western kenya it's what we need to do to
keep our culture alive and I think rafa
size is really doing much in in
promoting our culture ripasso didn't
have the funds to buy his drums sound
boxes or harps so he started building
them by collecting used and natural
materials like the sisal plant animal
skins wood or metal
sometimes he finds the cans he needs for
his rattles at Nairobi's dump sites I
saw the struggle of people asking so
where do we get that mighty glad we get
that route where do we get that pecky
where do we get that manga Leo sudoku no
I so I decided know how I will travel to
these places I'll learn how to make them
and I'll learn how I'll learn these
sounds and bring them close to the
people
the nia TT is repulses principal
instrument this eight string harp
originated in Egypt it was later played
by the luo people of Kenya the lower for
Strings symbolized the first four days
after a boy's birth and the upper for
Strings represent the first four days
after a man's death it is traditionally
played only by men I believe that
whatever we are doing will change many
for example you know the kids will only
do whatever they see every day I think
it's necessary for them to learn this so
that it's something that is passing
because house I also find people playing
them so that is what that is how i also
got inspired john ripasso chino teaches
youth how to play these traditional
instruments free of charge he's
dedicated to upholding his grandmother's
cultural traditions today he performs
for audiences whenever he can to make
this ancient music popular once again